hallo
herzlich willkommen in meine taten welt
heute möchte ich euch zeigen wie ich
meine sind schnecken mache die sitzen
schlitten werden aus hefeteig gemacht
aus süßem hefeteig ich habe euch ja in
meinem allerersten video in meinem lust
auf video gezeigt wie man hefeteig
herstellt es gibt aber verschiedene
verfahren wie immer live talk machen
kann und zwar - ob die kalte führung
gemacht so nennt man das einfach wenn
man die den hefeteig auf einmal
zubereitet also einfach etwas lauwarmer
milch benutzt um den hefeteig zu
vermischen
heute werde ich euch die weitere also
die zweite möglichkeit zeigen wie man
hefeteig machen kann nämlich die warme
führung und zwar mit einem vorteil der
vorteig hat den vorteil dass der gesamte
tag später dann eben schneller geht das
heißt wenn ihr euch am anfang kurz die
zeit nimmt und den vortrag vorbereitet
und den ebenso eine viertelstunde gehen
lasst dann wird der teig später eben
schneller gehen und ihr könnt ihn
schneller verarbeiten
die zutaten sind die gleichen dennoch
stelle ich solche ist eben kurz vor und
danach gehts auch gleich weiter für den
hefeteig braucht ihr 580 gramm zucker
einen teelöffel salz 250 milliliter
mädels die habe ich jetzt schon etwas
erwärmt also die slow war ein würfel
hefe da war gefroren
den hab ich jetzt einfach bei
zimmertemperatur auftauen lassen 80
gramm weiche butter und ein ei zuerst
packe ich jetzt die hilfe auf und
dadurch dass sie gefroren war hat sie
jetzt eben keine trockene konsistenz
messen ist jetzt eher etwas klebrig
das mache ich generell so dass ich würde
lieber einfrieren einfach damit ich
immer frische hilfe gehabt weil man
frische hefe im kühlschrank nicht zu
lange lagern da und das geht jetzt in
meine milch und dann könnte die täterin
schön auflösen
hier gebe ich jetzt noch etwas von dem
zucker mit dazu damit die hilfe
besser aufgehen kann dann gebe ich mein
geld in meine rührschüssel ich später
den teig verkneten möchte und ich mache
es natürlich in einer küchenmaschine
können es aber auch per hand verkneten
da gebt ihr eine mulde rein so ein
kleines loch eine vertiefung und da
kommt jetzt die hefe milchzucker
mischung rein
die bestäubung ich jetzt mit dem mädel
vom rand das denke ich jetzt schön ab
und lasst es an einem warmen ort etwa 15
minuten ruhe
hefeteig sollte grundsätzlich einem
warmen ort gehen lassen denn hefepilze
also kleine mikroorganismen und die
vermehrung teilen sich eben unter
bestimmten bedingungen und es sind
einmal die luft die feuchtigkeit die
wärme und die nahrung und nahrung denn
einfach das wovon sie sich ernähren kann
praktisch also hier zum beispiel der
zucker deswegen wird beim vorteil etwas
zucker mit zur hefe gegeben damit die
hefe sich eben schneller vermehren
urteilen kann und somit der hefeteig
später eben besser aufgeht
mein vorteil eine viertelstunde an einem
bau nord und hier seht jetzt deutlich
dass der gärungsprozess eben begonnen
hat nämlich weil hier am mehr risse
erkennbar sind und weil eben der teig
richtig hoch gegangen ist und so wie der
teig jetzt weiter verarbeitet jetzt gebe
ich hier einfach noch das salz mit dass
den restlichen zucker und das ei und an
der stelle kann ich jetzt auch schon die
butter mit rein geben weil ihr der
gärungsprozess von der hefe schon
begonnen hat wenn ihr keinen vorteil
macht dann durch die hefe die guter
erster zu geben wenn die hefe mit den
anderen zutaten verrührt ist weil das
fett eben verhindert dass sich die hilfe
mit den anderen fällen verbindet und
sich somit vermehrt und jetzt dass ich
den teig schön durch zählt
zeit noch etwas zu feucht ist wie meine
her
dann dürft ihr da gerne noch etwas mehl
dazugeben wenn der teig zum fest ist
gebt ihr noch etwas milch dazu so habe
ich meine teig jetzt auf einer bemehlten
arbeitsfläche gegeben und den einmal
schön zu einer kugel formen und beim
hefeteig ist mehr auf endlich mehr
das urteil kann man richtig schön lange
kneten je länger ein geknetet wird umso
besser
seid ihr richtig schöne konsistenz
richtig schön weich und stand schön von
außen nach innen in die mitte legen und
zu einer kugel formen die kugel gibt ihr
mit etwas mehl in eine schüssel zurück
und gibt auch mal auf die oberfläche und
das ganze denke ich jetzt wieder ab und
schloss den wieder an einem warmen ort
ruhen
ich mache das meist im ofen den schauen
dich auf 40 grad und mache ihnen dann
wieder aus und was ihnen da schön
ausruhen bis er sich verdoppelt hat das
wird jetzt etwa eine halbe stunde gehen
ihr seht der drei hat es richtig an
volumen zugenommen
und jetzt nehme ich ihn heraus und gebe
ihn auf meine bemehlten arbeitsfläche
leicht richtig schön luft drin in dem
hefeteig
und wenn ihr den hefeteig noch etwas
locker haben wollt noch feinen pariser
knetet ihn jetzt wieder durch und drückt
die ganze luft raus und dann stellt er
noch mal an einem warmen ort und so
erhaltet ihr eben einen feineren hilfe
aber mir reicht es jetzt lasse das ganze
nochmal gehen wenn ich später alles
geformt habe und jetzt muss der teig
ausgerollt werden da er ständig klebrig
deswegen dem ich da ganz ganz viel mit
runter damit nicht an der arbeitsfläche
liegen bleibt
jetzt rollte dann richtig schön eckig
aus ich bin jetzt da immer ganz gern
mein ikea schneidebrett so als größen
orientierung als nächstes braucht die
folgende zutaten ihr braucht etwas
butter die habe ich jetzt in der
mikrowelle erwärmt das in etwa 50 gramm
ihr braucht sind und zucker daraus mache
ich gleich zimt zucker und wer lust hat
dann kann auch ein paar mandeln oder
haselnüssen mit dazu geben so gehackt
hat und hat noch ein bisschen eine
andere konsistenz mit drin
wie gesagt gebe ich immer etwas zimt zu
meinem zucker macht den deckel zu und
schüttelt es euch und dann habt euren
zehn zu kommen und jetzt nehmt ihr euch
einfach die flüssige butter und verteilt
die schön auf eurer teig hatte
nicht alles auf brauchen nur so viel wie
ihr braucht und dann nehmt ihr euch den
zucker und streut den gleichmäßig über
möchte gibt hier jetzt eben noch ein
paar mandeln mit drauf und dann rollt
ihr den teig von der einen seite auf als
sowie beim luft heben auch und dann legt
das euch so hin dass ihr einen
gleichmäßigen strang habt also das
sollte dann auch gleichmäßig dick sein
und dann nehme ich mir ein lineal ihr
könnt auch ohne machen und schneiden wir
hier 2 5 zentimeter dicke scheiben ab
und danach nehmen durch irgendeine form
ich nehme da ganz gern meinen
verstellbaren bekamen von nomura den
stelle ich so auf 29 30 cm und setzt
dann diese muss schmecken da rein und je
nachdem wie groß die form ist können
dass sie eben darin schön platzieren
das kann auch eine eckige form sein oder
backblech und etwas tieferes
hier bewusst
das ganze jetzt noch mal gehen die
lücken werden sich dann später natürlich
auffüllen weil ja der hefeteig aufgeht
wenn ihr den ring etwas enger stellt
dann habt ihr den vorteilen das mache
ich mal kurz das das ganze dann eher in
die höhe geht und ich denn die breite
also falls er eher höheren kuchen haben
wollt und so lasst ihr das nochmal
abgedeckt an einem warmen ort etwa 10
bis 15 minuten ruhe und wer keine lust
auf einem großen kuchen hat der nimmt
sich einfach silikon backförmchen und
gibt da diese diesem tag rein
ich habe jetzt jemand das den anfang und
das ende ihr könnt praktisch so rum oder
ebenso um reinlegen
so könnte auch den ganzen tag backen
also wie ihr seht müsste da keinen
großen kuchen machen sondern könnte es
auch so schön portioniert backen
am besten eignet sich das silikon
backform und da kann man das nicht
stellt ist ja gut raus lösen papier
backförmchen rate ich euch ab weil da
der teig daran klebt später die lasse
ich jetzt auch einmal gehen und zeigt
euch dann mit es aussieht wenn der teig
dann aufgegangen ist seht es etwas so
aus also ihr seht auch der teig in den
muffin förmchen ist richtig schön hoch
und jetzt nehmt ihr euch eure restliche
butter und bestreicht einfach den teig
damit das schützt das gebäck auch von
austrocknen gibt noch mal einen schönen
glanz und eben auch einen schönen
geschmack und so werde ich das ganze
jetzt bei 190 bis 200 grad etwa 25 bis
30 minuten backen
die muffins können natürlich schon etwas
vor heraus die sehr kleine aber der
kuchen sollte eine schöne gold frauen
oberfläche haben und dann kann daraus
zu sehen jetzt die kleinen muffins aus
die habe ich jetzt schon nach 20 minuten
raus geholt wie es sein könnte sich eine
richtig schöne rosen formen und
gleichzeitig den kompletten kuchen so
siegels der fett gebackene kuchen aus
und darin dann noch schön warm ist
bereite ich jetzt noch eine klausur fort
ihr könnt natürlich auch nicht mehr ganz
normale puderzucker betonen ja so drauf
machen
ihr könnt das ganze auch nur mit
puderzucker bestäuben oder auch einfach
so lassen
ich zeige euch jetzt eine andere
variante und zwar braucht ihr dafür
frischkäse puderzucker und zitrone
ich habe jetzt hier etwa zwei esslöffel
butter zucker und gebe einen esslöffel
frischkäse mit rein moment spritzer
zitrone
man wird es kurz miteinander verrührt
und ihr werdet merken was dann der
frischkäse flüssiger wird durch den
zucker die klümpchen haus das ist so und
frosting dann erinnert das ganze eher so
ein amerikanisches rezept und dann
verteilt die den gruß hier schön auf dem
wagen kuchen
die kleinen natürlich auch die bekommen
auch eine schöne klasse
der kuchen ist es dann auch schon fertig
jetzt in der liebsten gerne warm hell
steht mir aber nicht die show und mit
diesem rezept wollte ich euch noch
einmal zeigen wie eine andere variante
zu tiefe teigs geht also die zubereitung
weise und ich finde diese variante
besser mit dem vorteig weil da zeigt
dann wirklich besser aufgeht und
schneller auf geht mit einem kleinen
aufwand vorher
das rezept ist natürlich sehr wandelbar
ihr könnt daraus auch ganz normale muss
schmecken machen also diese einzelnen
muss schmecken und die damit sogar
beziehen und ausbildung könnte er auch
alles mögliche nehmen
jetzt wünsche ich euch viel spaß jetzt
wünsche euch viel spaß beim nachbacken
hoffe dass ich das mit gefallen hat
falls es euch keine schloss mit einem
daumen
also einen gefällt mir abonnieren meinen
kanal ist kostenlos wie ihr wollt und
den nächsten mal wieder
bis bald
so sieht jetzt dass sich gebackener
kuchen aus papier mann musste noch
pusten
schmeckt gut